we are just hours away from the Mega
Millions jackpot drawing the
785 million dollar prize it is the sixth
largest in history Mary Jane beliesza
joining us live at Arizona's last stop
in white Hills Arizona where people Mary
Jane lining up to buy a ticket so
excited ahead of tonight's drawing
gas station really crowds were packed
here much earlier but as you can see
behind me there are still people trying
to get their lottery tickets in before
that drawing deadline as people hope to
win that lucky jackpot now one of those
people is Patty Tomko she and a group of
friends drove here from Las Vegas they
make a trip to buy a lottery ticket
anytime the jackpot reaches over a
million dollars and if she wins she
hopes to go on vacation
I know we're all going on one Cruise
we're taking a big cruise together and
then
help other people who didn't get in with
us we're gonna throw a little money
their way
[Music]
TOMCO says she would love it if Nevada
had her own Lottery but doesn't mind the
drive to Arizona to buy a ticket either
and remember Arizona last stop gas
station in white Hills isn't the only
place where you can buy a lottery ticket
there are several other stops South from
here on your way to Kingman and of
course Kingman has many other places as
well where you can buy a lottery ticket
and also another spot is Prim that's
along the California Nevada border you
can also buy a ticket there so good luck
to everyone who bought a ticket
including myself reporting live from
White Hills Arizona Marriott news now